Yeah, one of my big advice big pieces of advice that I'd give for someone
learning how to program is, it's okay to look stupid like, it's okay not to
know what you're doing. Like it's, it's funny one of my big things going into
like, learning how to program was I had pride issues, where I was like I don't
want to look dumb, I don't want to ask for help. And asking for help like,
whether it's, you know, Googling it like Googling is my best friend when it
comes to things that I don't know or you know, even just asking someone next to
me. Like hey can you look over this code or forums like, there's so many
things, so many resources out there that are available. And you know, everyone
in constantly learning, that's the thing, is that like. For me like, looking
back the people that I was asking now that I know like what year they were when
I was asking its like, wow they are where I am now. And they were still
learning cause I'm still learning and so just knowing that its like its okay.
People you're always going to have someone that's like oh you're new but that's
OK you have to start somewhere.